we're getting to know the navy's first  ever black  female tactical jet pilot this is new  video of lieutenant junior grade  madeleine swegel in a just released navy  interview  she says she hopes her landmark feat  will inspire others to never give up  i guess i hope that my legacy will be  that there will be a lot of other  women and minority women and just  different  faces that come forward and  at least give the pipeline a shot you  know  like be encouraged and know that they  have all the tools that they need and  you know follow their dreams i think  tony mentioned her achievement uh a  little i  talked to the table a few weeks ago but  this is the first video we've seen over  the first interview  she remembers seeing the blue angels as  a child  and loving the fast planes well she's  achieved her dream grail gail  i love everything about her and i really  love when your dreams come true  so you go we are cheering her on